bonsoir à toutes et tous
comme chaque jeudi soir je viens faire
un point sur la situation épidémique en
france faire le point sur le front de la
colline 19 je le fais ce soir aux côtés
du ministre de l'économie des finances
et de la relance bruno le maire pourquoi
parce que la situation sanitaire et la
situation économique sont finalement les
deux faces d'une même médaille
il ne saurait y avoir de reprise
économique sans confiance et de
confiance sans notre capacité à lutter
avec efficacité contre cette épidémie
est notre système sanitaire pour bien
fonctionner a besoin d'une économie
solide mon message ce soir tiendra en
trois mots transparence prévisibilité et
responsabilisation transparence dans
l'accès aux données dont nous disposons
comme chaque semaine les prévisions les
modélisations l'état de la situation
sanitaire territoire par territoire
prévisibilité pour donner des outils aux
français pour savoir vers où l'hiver où
ils vont en fonction du lieu de vie dans
lequel ils résident
et puis responsabilisation parce que
dans cette lutte que nous menons cette
lutte acharnée contre la diffusion du
virus nous détenons chacun de nous une
part de la victoire par nos
comportements individuels et collectifs
par l'attention que nous portons à
chaque instant de notre quotidien à ne
pas transmettre le virus autour de nous
un point épidémiologique
d'abord la situation sanitaire
continuent hélas de se dégrader en
france c'est aussi le cas dans de
nombreux pays voisins certains sont dans
une situation sanitaire plus dégradée
que la nôtre et d'autres pays ont amorcé
une reprise épidémique
hélas depuis quelques jours ou quelques
semaines
il ya donc en france chaque jour de plus
en plus de personnes contaminées
de plus en plus de personnes malades et
de plus en plus de personnes qui font
par conséquent des formes graves avec un
impact hospitalier qui augmente
trois indicateurs rapide que vous
connaissez le taux d'incidence d'abord
en population générale
oui cette courbe qui
augmente avec une incidence à 116% mille
c'est à dire que pour cent mille
personnes en france 116 sont
actuellement porteuses du virus
symptomatique ou non deuxième indicateur
c'est le fameux facteur de reproduction
du virus le être c'est à dire combien de
personnes je vais contaminé si je suis
malade en une semaine
je rappelle que si le r tombe en dessous
de 1 ça veut dire qu'on est efficace et
qu'on freine l'épidémie s'il est au
dessus de 1
ça veut dire que l'épidémie continue
hélas d'évoluer je rappelle qu'au
printemps dernier le r était aux
alentours de 3 si j'étais malade je
risquer de contaminer trois personnes en
une semaine
aujourd'hui on estime aux alentours de
1,1 1,2 selon les indicateurs ça veut
dire que si je suis malade je risque de
contaminer 1,1 ou deux personnes
troisième indicateur c'est le taux de
positivité des tests sur 100 tests que
nous réalisons combien sont positifs 9%
9 % c'est un taux en augmentation et
c'est un taux élevé à titre de
comparaison lorsque nous avions réalisé
le déconfinement dans le pays ce taux de
positivité était aux alentours de 1%
pourquoi je vous parle de ces trois
indicateurs parce que c'est trois
indicateurs nous permettent de
déterminer des seuil d'épidémie des
seuils de gravité de la diffusion du
coronavirus sur le territoire national
et s'essaye nous ont permis à eux mêmes
de déterminer ses fameuses zones dites
zones d'alert sur lesquels je vais
revenir rapidement
d'abord la zone de circulation active
lorsque le virus commence à circuler on
dit que l'incidence est supérieure à 50
cas pour 100000 habitants la zone d'
alerte renforcée lorsque le virus
circule davantage et qu'il circule aussi
chez les personnes vulnérables ou
considère les personnes âgées de 65 ans
et plus la zone d' alerte maximale
c'est lorsque le virus circule vraiment
beaucoup en population générale chez les
ch et les personnes vulnérables et qu'on
enregistre un impact sanitaire
conséquent avec un taux d'occupation de
nos réanimation à l'échelle d'une région
de 30% par les malades du coronavirus et
enfin l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui ne
correspond à aucun territoire à date sur
le territoire national et qui correspond
à au moins 60 % des malades en ré a
atteint 2 coronavirus je vous rappelle
qu'il ya quinze jours nous avons classé
marseille et la guadeloupe en zone d'
alerte maximale
il y a quelques jours paris également à
basculer en zone d' alerte maximale les
mesures vous les connaissez la fermeture
totale des barres un protocole renforcé
dans les restaurants par exemple on ne
peut pas être plus de six personnes sur
une même table dans un restaurant les
espaces entre les tables et les chaises
de deux groupes différents sont
augmentés et les restaurateurs sont
amenés à vous proposer d'inscrire vos
coordonnées pour qu'on puisse vous
rappeler si d'aventuré un cluster et est
identifié dans ledit restaurant il est
fondamental que chacun participe quand
je parle de responsabilisation c'est
cela que chacun participe à ce protocole
sanitaire renforcée qui n'y a pour seul
objectif d'éviter des contaminations
groupées dans ces métropoles il ya deux
semaines nous avons également classé
bordeaux rennes rouen et nice en zone
dite d' alerte renforcée c'est le niveau
d'alerté en dessous avec cette fois ci
une fermeture des bars prononcé à 22
heures l'interdiction des grands
rassemblements au delà de 1000 personnes
et la limitation des regroupements y
compris sur la voie publique en dessous
de 10 personnes à nouveau pour augmenter
la distanciation sociale et éviter que
le virus ne circule davantage la
situation s'est dégradée dans plusieurs
métropoles
ces derniers jours qu'ils vont nous
conduire à basculer un certain nombre de
métropoles dans des zones d'alert
supérieur tout d'abord s'agissant de
dijon dijon que vous voyez apparaître a
maintenant un taux d'incidence un taux
d'incidence chez les personnes âgées qui
justifie son classement en zone d'
alerte renforcée
de la même manière que clermont ferrand
a une incidence en population générale
une incidence en populations vulnérables
qui justifie son classement en zone d'
alerte renforcée pour ces deux
métropoles
ce passage se fera dès samedi matin
ensuite la situation est encore plus
dégradée dans d'autres territoires
lille tout d'abord voulait voir
apparaître sur l'écran avec une
incidence très élevé une incidence chez
les personnes vulnérables également très
élevé et vous le voyez un taux
d'occupation des réanimations par des
malades atteints du coronavirus qui a
atteint les 30%
grenoble présente les mêmes
caractéristiques c'est à dire un taux
d'incidence cumulé en population
générale en populations vulnérables et
une part de malades atteints du coc vide
en réanimation supérieure à 30%
la situation s'est également dégradée
pour lyon où l'incidence a dépassé
également les cotes d' alerte et la part
des patients en réanimation à l'échelle
régionale et donc la même qu'à grenoble
c'est à dire supérieure à 30% et enfin
saint-etienne qui présentent peu ou prou
les mêmes caractéristiques épidémique
pour ces quatre métropole lille grenoble
lyon et saint-etienne un passage en zone
d' alerte maximale a été décidée par le
président de la république en conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale ce
passage sera effectif à compter de
samedi matin par ailleurs deux autres
métropoles présente des caractéristiques
épidémique inquiétante
il s'agit d'abord de toulouse avec un
taux d'incidence qui n'est pas encore
arrivé à la cote d' alerte maximale et
une part de patients en réanimation qui
augmentent et qui pourrait franchir les
30% dans les prochains jours par
ailleurs vous voyait les traits bleus
qui correspondent à haut taux réels
d'occupation d'airé à part des malades
qu vide alors que les très vert
correspondent aux modélisations vous
voyez que la situation sanitaire s'est
aggravée un peu plus vite qu'escompté à
toulouse
et c'est également le cas pour
montpellier qui sur la diapositive
suivante avec là aussi une dégradation
sanitaire qui nous font craindre le
franchissement des 3 indicateurs dans
les prochains jours pour toulouse et
montpellier
à l'instar de ce qui a été fait pour
paris la semaine dernière nous nous
donnons quelques jours d'observation
pour vérifier si la situation sanitaire
se dégrade et si les indicateurs sont
franchis une bascule en zone d' alerte
maximale pourrait être opéré
si à lundi matin pour l'ensemble de ces
métropoles
les élus locaux ont été consultés
beaucoup d'entre eux la plupart d'entre
eux ont été reçus par le premier
ministre au cours des derniers jours
l'ensemble de ses élus ont été contactés
par le préfet le directeur général de
l'agencé régionale de santé de manière à
les alerter sur la dégradation des
indicateurs épidémique et leur annoncer
que la bascule avait hélas de grands
risques d'être opéré et dans les
prochains jours donc avant la mise en
place pratique de cette bascule
la concertation se poursuivra entre les
préfets et des jets de rs et les élus
pour déterminer le périmètre
d'application territorial de ces mesures
et la nature précise de ces mesures
malgré cette situation difficile et ces
annonces difficile je tiens à préciser
qu'il y a aussi des signes
d'amélioration dans plusieurs endroits
du territoire national il faut aussi
prendre des bonnes nouvelles quand on
peut les observer signe que les mesures
que nous mettons en oeuvre pour lutter
contre la circulation du virus et que
les mesures qui sont prises d'ailleurs
par les élus locaux de même pour freiner
la diffusion du virus sont efficaces
ainsi la nièvre et le morbihan quitte
les départements classés en zone d'
alerte et on enregistre une amélioration
sensible de la situation sanitaire à
nice à bordeaux une inflexion positive
également est observé à rennes ainsi
qu'à aix marseille
je le dis tout de suite avant de crier
victoire il faut avoir suffisamment de
recul être sûr que dans la durée
la circulation du virus se réduit et que
dans la durée
l'impact sanitaire sur les hôpitaux se
réduit il n'est donc pas à date de
bascule dans une zone d' alerte
inférieurs pour les villes que j'ai
cités mais nous surveillons cela
quotidiennement et nous espérons pouvoir
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles peut être
la semaine prochaine pour alléger des
mesures il faut être sûr qu'elles ont
été suffisamment appliqués et qu'elles
sont efficaces pour éviter un effet yoyo
deux reprises épidémique si on allait
j'ai trop tôt au-delà de ces
informations je voulais je le disais
appelé à la responsabilisation
quand je dis que chaque français peut
agir
contre la diffusion du virus c'est que
nous devons être vigilants dans tous les
moments de notre quotidien c'est
difficile c'est un effort permanent
je lui ai dit la semaine dernière quand
on porte le masque et qu'on fait
attention aux personnes qui sont à côté
de nous dans le métro au travail au
restaurant
ce n'est pas pour relâcher les efforts
quand on rentre chez soi à la maison
hélas les hôpitaux et les réanimations
en particulier hospitalise beaucoup de
malades qui ont été contaminées dans un
cadre familial est en réalité ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que les malades
qui sont aujourd'hui en réanimation ont
été contaminés il ya deux semaines par
des gens qui ne savaient pas eux mêmes
qu'ils étaient contagieux souvent parce
qu'ils étaient plus jeunes est
asymptomatique et eux-mêmes c'était
contaminé quelques jours auparavant par
exemple dans les bars hélas ou dans des
rassemblements festifs ou non est en
fait ce passage du virus des personnes
jeunes qui font peu de symptômes et qui
sont en général peu sensibles aux virus
dans les personnes vulnérables se fait
souvent dans un cadre familial même si
vous souhaitez recevoir vos proches même
si vous souhaitez recevoir des amis même
si vous recevez votre famille vos
enfants vos petits enfants
vous devez garder de la distance vous
devez porter le masque et faire
extrêmement attention autour de vous
parfois un écart d'une heure dans une
semaine où on a fait attention suffit
hélas pour tomber sur une personne qui
était contagieuse sans le savoir et se
retrouver soi-même quelques jours ou
quelques semaines plus tard à l'hôpital
un mot également pour paris vous l'avez
peut-être entendu ce matin le directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé à
déclencher le plan blanc dans l'ensemble
des hôpitaux franciliens
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le plan blanc
ça veut dire que la part de patients
coded en réanimation dans les hôpitaux
franciliens augmente et que la pression
sanitaires se fait de plus en plus forte
dans les hôpitaux parisiens et
franciliens en général obligeant à des
programmes et des soins puisque canton
des programmes une chirurgie programmée
imaginez une chirurgie d'une prothèse de
hanche pour de l'arthrose par exemple eh
bien on peut libérer un bloc opératoire
éviter d'occuper un lit de réanimation
et parfois même transformé le bloc
opératoire en salle de réanimation
donc à mesure qu'on augmente nos
capacités d'accueil hospitalière on peut
le faire on peut monter jusqu'à 12
milles
r mais à mesure qu'on augmente nos
capacités de réanimation on est obligé
de déprogrammer de retarder des soins
utiles voire indispensables pour des
gens qui ne sont pas atteints du
coronavirus est par ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'il ya un malade en réanimation
il y à un malade qui fait une forme
grave ce n'est pas neutre ne suffit pas
de se dire qu'on a des lits de
réanimation pour pouvoir faire face
notre objectif c'est qu'il y ait le
moins possible de patients en
réanimation et pour cela il faut qu'il y
ait de moins possible de malades qui se
contaminent et enfin mon dernier message
sera pour les soignants de notre pays
qui sans relâche mois après mois jour
après jour font face à la première vague
d'abord à cette recrudescence épidémique
désormais je veux leur dire le soutien
de la nation toute entière nous sommes
avec vous dans la lutte que vous menez
les décisions que nous prenons qui sont
difficiles et qui impacte la vie de
nombreux français sont des décisions que
nous prenons pour protéger les hôpitaux
pour protéger les français
nous tenons à vous soignants nous vous
remercions pour votre mobilisation de
tous les instants et j'en profite pour
rappeler celles et ceux qui le peuvent
également à rejoindre les renforts à
travers la réserve sanitaire ou les
plateformes régionales pour venir prêter
main forte notamment dans les ehpad
mais également dans les hôpitaux et
enfin un mot aussi pour les soignants
qui en ville se bat avec cette épidémie
qui font partie de ces premières lignes
à mesure que la prise la pression
épidémiques augmente les soignants sont
soumis également en ville un travail
toujours plus fort et intense donc un
merci pour les soignants je vais passer
maintenant la parole à bruno le maire
merci cher olivier mesdames messieurs je
voudrais tout d'abord m'associer aux
mots que olivier ferrand vient d'avoir
pour les personnels de soignants je peux
en témoigner personnellement nos
personnels soignants sont
exceptionnelles dévouement de
compétences de courage et de
professionnalisme comme olivier verront
vient de l'indiquer
nous sommes confrontés à une
recrudescence de l'épidémie dans un
certain nombre de territoires qui nous
oblige à prendre de nouvelles mesures
sanitaires qui sont rigoureuses mais qui
sont nécessaires mesures sur des
fermetures de bar sur des règles
sanitaires dans certains restaurants ne
jurent que aussi un impact sur
l'activité économique de notre pays
les français sont inquiets de la
situation sanitaire
mais s'ils sont tout aussi inquiets de
la situation économique et nous voulons
répondre avec la même force que celle
que nous avons eue depuis le début de la
crise aux préoccupations de tous les
français sur cette situation économique
je pense évidemment à tous les salariés
je pense aux dizaines de milliers d'auto
entrepreneur de commerçants d'artisans
d'indépendants en particulier dans les
secteurs qui sont les plus touchés par
les conséquences de la crise
l'hôtellerie la restauration les cafés
les salles de sport le monde de la
culture le monde de l'événementiel ou
associé à l'événementiel je pense aux
photographes au fleuriste au graphiste
au traiteur aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
moins de mariages beaucoup moins de fait
très peu de rassemblements donc moins de
fleurs à commander moins de photographe
en activité - de graphistes pour envoyer
des cartons d'invitation moins de
traiteur et bien nous voulons
accompagner chacune de ces professions
depuis le début de la crise nous avons
fait un choix clair avec le président de
la république et le premier ministre
protéger au maximum les salariés comme
les entreprises
ce choix je tiens le redis elle nous a
permis d'éviter des centaines de
milliers de licenciements et des
dizaines de milliers de faillite en
france je veux le dire avec beaucoup de
force à nos compatriotes nous
continuerons à protéger les salariés et
les entreprises tant que la crise
sanitaire sera là et nous continuerons
d'adapter les dispositifs à la situation
sanitaire et aux contraintes qui peuvent
en découler pour le monde économique
l'un des instruments les plus efficaces
pour faire face à cette crise économique
et soutenir les très petites entreprises
les indépendants les commerçants ça a
été le fonds de solidarité que nous
avons mis en place dès le début du mois
de mars
il a concerné 1,7 million d'entreprises
pour un montant total de dépenses de
plus de 6 milliards d'euros il a associé
l'état et les régions que je tiens à
remercier pour leur engagement
mais nous voyons bien aujourd'hui que ce
fonds ne permet pas de couvrir toutes
les situations qui résulte des nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires
nous avons donc décidé d'élargir et de
renforcer le fonds de solidarité
ce fonds de solidarité comme vous le
savez il est réservé depuis le mois de
juillet au secteur du tourisme de
l'événementiel de la culture du sport
mais certaines activités en étaient
exclus alors qu'elles sont directement
impactés par les conséquences de la
crise sanitaire
nous allons donc inclure ces nouvelles
activités
je pense aux fleuristes je pense aux
blanchisserie qui dépendent très
directement de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration
je pense aux bouquinistes des quêtes
paris puisqu'il ya moins de touristes à
paris aujourd'hui je pense aux arts de
la table puisqu'il y a moins de
restaurants ouverts
je pense aux graphistes nous allons
ajouter au total 75 mille entreprises
qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de ce fonds
de solidarité elles sont 150 milles en
bénéficier aujourd'hui elles seront 75
milles supplémentaires
avec l'élargissement de ce fonds de
solidarité en deuxième lieu de aides du
fonds de solidarité était réservée aux
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
c'était bien l'objectif au départ
soutenir les plus petites entreprises
soutenir des autos de soutenir les
indépendants nous allons élargir cette
aide à toutes les entreprises jusqu'à 50
salariés
toutes les entreprises des secteurs
d'activité que je viens d'indiquer ce
fonds de solidarité pour en bénéficier
il faut soit faire l'objet d'une
fermeture administrative soit avoir
perdu 80% de son chiffre d'affaires
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs nous ont dit
80% c'est trop strict il faut que vous
baissiez ce seuil
nous avons donc décidé de baisser ce
seuil jusqu'à une perte de 70 % de son
chiffre d'affaires vous voyez que ces
modifications sont profondes
nous élargissons le nombre de
bénéficiaires de ce fonds de solidarité
nous le portons aux entreprises jusqu'à
50 salariés dans les secteurs que j'ai
indiquées et pour en bénéficier soit
vous est fermé sauf à pervez perdu non
pas 80% mais 70% de votre chiffre
d'affaires je rappelle que pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce procédé rites et les
dispositifs sont extrêmement simple il
suffit de vous rendre sur le site
impots.gouv.fr et c'est sur une simple
base des cars à thouars que vous pouvez
bénéficier de ce fonds et je rappelle
que la semaine dernière nous avons
décidé de porter l'aide du fonds de
solidarité de 1500 euros à une aide
mensuelle qui ira jusqu'à 10000 euros
c'est donc un renforcement massif du
fonds de solidarité qui est proposé
aujourd'hui pour tenir compte des
conséquences des règles sanitaires
nouvelles qui vont s'appliquer à tous
les secteurs de l'hôtellerie des barres
de la restauration de la culture de
l'événementiel ou du sport
le deuxième élément de soutien massif
c'est l'activité partielle le chômage
partiel a permis d'éviter des centaines
de milliers de licenciements et je pense
qu'il est conforme à l'idée que nous
nous faisons notre modèle social
il faut protéger les salariés
et protéger les compétences c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous permettra de
rebondir plus vite
ensuite parce que nous ne serons pas
priver des compétences qui ont été
touchés par la crise
toutes les entreprises des secteurs du
tourisme de l'événementiel de la culture
du sport pourront bénéficier d'une prise
en charge du chômage partiel par l'état
à 100% avec zéro reste à charge pour
l'entreprise jusqu'à la fin de l'année
2020 cela permettra à ces entreprises de
faire face aux difficultés sanitaires
enfin la dernière mesure ce sont les
exonérations de charges sociales les
entreprises fermées administrativement
ou qui font l'objet de restrictions
horaires peuvent travailler jusqu'à 22h
par exemple pour les bars et qui font
une perte de chiffre d'affaires d'au
moins 50% sont exonérés de toute
cotisation sociale jusqu'à ce que les
mesures de restriction soit levée et je
tiens à signaler que les nouvelles
activités dont je viens de vous parler
la blanchisserie les arts de la table
pourront bénéficier de manière
rétroactive des exonérations de charges
sociales sur la période qui couvre le
mois de février au mois de mai 2020 donc
toutes les entreprises qui désormais
bénéficient du fonds de solidarité qui
ont bénéficié de cet élargissement
bénéficie également des exonérations de
charges sociales de février à mai 2020
dont elle n'avait pas pu bénéficier
auparavant c'est aussi un effort très
important
un mot enfin toujours sur ces mesures
sur les questions de trésorerie parce
que je sais que c'est une préoccupation
majeure de beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui se disent nous avons
contracté un prêt garanti par l'état il
est à un taux particulièrement
attractives 0 25% qui inclut la garantie
de l'état
on arrive au bout de ce prêt il va lui
falloir qu'on prolonge la durée de ce
prêt parce qu'on peut pas le rembourser
tout de suite que ce que les chiffres
d'affaires ne sont pas suffisants nous
voulons prolonger
quel va être le taux je confirme que le
taux sera au maximum de 2 5% et qu'il
sera compris dans une fourchette entre 1
et 2,5 pour cent pour les tpe et les pme
et que cette fourchette de taux de 1 à 2
5% qui est particulièrement attractive
inclut la garantie de l'état qui
représente un point là dessus donc ce
sont des taux qui sont particulièrement
attractifs pour ces très petites
entreprises
et cpm pour les entreprises qui
souhaiteraient bénéficier de fonds
propres je rappelle qu'elles pourront
bénéficier à partir de janvier 2021 nous
continuons à travailler là dessus
deux prêts participatifs de 7 ans
minimum
un taux qui reste à déterminer l'intérêt
de ces prêts participatifs c'est que ce
sont des quasi fonds propres ça ne pèse
pas sur l'endettement des entreprises
donc elles pourront se remettre à
investir ce qui est absolument essentiel
pour notre économie
un mot pour conclure d'abord pour
remercier toutes les fédérations
professionnelles tous les chefs
d'entreprise tous les indépendants tous
les commerçants tous les artisans avec
lesquels nous travaillons main dans la
main depuis le début de la crise ça a
été ma méthode depuis le premier jour de
la crise économique
rencontrer tous les acteurs toutes les
semaines pour évaluer les dispositifs et
les corriger pour répondre à leurs
demandes
est ce ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
en présentant ses annonces sur le front
solidarité d'activité partielle des
charges sociales ou les prêts garantis
par l'état
ces discussions qui ont permis d'adapter
des dispositifs et de les rendre les
plus efficaces et les plus opérationnel
possible et j'ai personnellement un
souci constant d'efficacité de
réactivité pour protéger nos
entrepreneurs et s'il faut à nouveau
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent ajustez tel ou tel dispositif
pour qu'ils soient plus efficaces et
qu'ils répondent à la préoccupation d'un
entrepreneur sur le terrain nous le
ferons et je veux dire à chaque
entrepreneur qui nous écoutent
il ya tous les salariés qui travaillent
avec eux que j'ai une conscience intime
de ce que cela peut représenter pour un
restaurateur qui a fait des efforts
considérables qui achetaient des vitres
en plexiglas qui a modifié sa carte qui
s'est équipée en masques angèle pour ses
salariés de devoir à nouveau compléter
encore ses règles et je sais qu'il y a
les jeux parfois beaucoup de désarroi
parfois du désespoir parfois de la
colère que nous comprenons ces
sentiments mais que nous voulons y
répondre par des décisions efficaces et
rapides et comme apporter tout